well legendary rock and roll singer Tina
Turner is setting the record straight
she wrote a new memoir that chronicles
her illustrious career and her personal
tragedy it's published by atria an
imprint of Simon & Schuster which is a
division of CBS the memoir includes the
abuse by her former husband and partner
Ike Turner Gale travelled to Zurich
Switzerland to meet Turner in a
wide-ranging interview the singer opens
up about some of her insecurities the
Ike and Tina Turner revue became one of
the most successful acts of the late 60s
Tina says she faced competition from
other big female singers but I was the
only one that danced
and I remember Lily Richard said Tina
dances you know it's hard for us to
compete with her because I always did
the twist I always danced and state but
you had that voice too
and I had the strange boys that most
girls singers didn't
[Music]
how does your voice sound to you deep
and even he goes deeper so do you like
your voice to know do you think you have
a good voice you know in the beginning I
didn't I thought it was kind of ugly
because it was didn't sound like Diana
Ross but then afterwards I thought yeah
it sounds like the guys
[Music]
surprisingly Turner says she did not
think she was attractive you know I
never thought I was attractive that's
why the wigs and the makeup and the
dress I had to really make myself pretty
oh I have to work on that and I look at
the pictures now and I said oh yeah I
did a good job
yeah I move it from that to this and you
can see Gail's interview with Tina
Turner Sunday on CBS Sunday morning and
we will have more Monday right here on
CBS this morning